there's maybe no painting in the history
of the forum more worthy of analysis
then diego velázquez las meninas what
we're talking about here is a masterwork
by an artist late in his life but at the
height of his powers determined to drive
into this canvas the sum total of his
talent his experience and his intellect
Velasquez had been by then a court
painter for the Spanish King Philip the
fourth for over 30 years indeed he was a
favorite of Philips painting his
portrait many times in advancing in
salary and rank all the way up to
Chamberlain of the palace responsible
for decorating this great Alcazar of
Madrid with all its many artworks so
it's no surprise that for his
masterpiece Velazquez sets his painting
in the palace itself the place he knew
best specifically in his own studio
adorned with paintings that he himself
chose now they're a little bit hard to
see but we know what they are based on
histories of the space and it's no
accident that he chooses these paintings
specifically but we'll get to that a bit
later first let's take a look at the
main action of the scene so much hits
you right away maybe the first thing you
see is the little girl Margaret Theresa
the then only living child of the king
or maybe you see that mirror showing
reflected images of the king and queen
themselves or maybe the first thing that
stands out to you is that six of the
nine characters represented here are
staring beyond the picture plane which
is to say at you that fact alone gives
this image it's great sense of
spontaneity as if it were a snapshot
Velazquez captures the moment just when
several of these figures are noticing
something some like these three have yet
to notice it in the case of little
princess all that's moved so far is her
eyes but though the moment depicted is
spontaneous the composition of the
objects is anything but you have here a
real clinic in composing group scenes
what Velasquez has done in this group of
eleven including the mirror images of
the king queen this arranged an
extraordinary number of links and
contrasts that slides your eyes back and
forth across the canvas the first thing
to notice perhaps is the obsession here
with grouping twos and threes everyone
here but the princess can be split into
pairs the male and female dwarf the two
chaperones here the curtseying maid and
the palace official in the back corridor
the king and the queen and the mirror
and Velasquez and the maid kneeling to
offer the princess a drink notice also
that these are all male-female pairs
when these pairings accentuate the
princess as the focus of the scene but
you could also split the group up into
threes the princess with our two maids
the dog and the two dwarves and the two
palace officials with what now occurs to
us are mirrored couples see also that
these two groups of three internally
made up of doubles and triples are all
on the same horizontal plane this group
of six also draws the entirety of the
paintings three-dimensional space our
eye is drawn from Velasquez in the
foreground to the palace official in the
distance as they're wearing similar
black garb and stand in line with the
two doorways on the back walls the
chaperones in the middle ground linked
to the king and queen in the background
which simultaneously brings the z-axis
all the way forward beyond the picture
itself intimating a depth that we can't
even see it's amazing
what you might not have realized is that
this motif of twos and threes has
already been established in the frames
on the back wall with two giant canvases
overtop two door frames and the central
mirror of that bottom triple the right
sides of the frames correspond with the
princess and her two maids moving the
eyes naturally from the king and queen
to their daughter but the eyes are also
drawn from the mirror to the right that
lighted passage framing the palace
official the space of this light and
rectangle is equal to that of the
mirror and they're put on the same
horizontal plane as well indeed because
of its brightness like the brightness of
the little princess bathed in light were
drawn to it just as much as the other
two in these three elements of Las
Meninas we have three central focus
points unlike da Vinci's Last Supper for
example where all elements in the
painting point toward Jesus Christ Las
Meninas is more ambiguous letting the
viewer vacillate between multiple
centers of weight being a court painter
for the royal family it's obvious why
Velazquez would want to highlight the
royal couple and their daughter but
what's significant about the back
hallway well this gets at a long-running
debate about the significance of this
mirror what exactly is it reflecting a
number of critics have seen it as the
reflection of the actual king and queen
standing like we said beyond the picture
plane putting the viewer literally in
the shoes of royalty but a closer
examination of the one-point perspective
of this image reveals something else the
vanishing point of Las Meninas is not
here but here in the lighted doorway to
the right what does this mean well it
means that the eye of this painting so
to speak isn't opposite the mirror but
opposite the door so the mirror doesn't
reflect directly back at us
it reflects at an angle an angle that
puts its image on another unseen aspect
of Las Meninas the canvas that Velasquez
is working on now for a moment let's get
back to the paintings in the upper half
of this picture these are copies of two
paintings by Peter Paul Rubens a hero of
Alaska's and they tell similar stories
in this case both from Ovid's
metamorphoses in the right the Mortal
marcia's challenges the god apollo to a
flute playing contests in the left the
god athena challenges the mortal Arachne
to a weaving contest
in other words these are two contests
between mortals and gods on the subject
of the arts Marsyas losses and Arachne
wins but both are punished by their gods
in the end for failing to recognize the
divine source of the artistic endeavor
such stories are extremely relevant to
Las Meninas because in the end this is a
painting about painting itself in
Velasquez as time painting still didn't
hold the same kind of noble place as
poetry and music Las Meninas in all its
splendid effects is a vigorous argument
for the virtue of painting whether it
comes from the heavens or from the
lifelong practice of craft and this gets
at the heart of the mirror the vanishing
point and the multiple centers of focus
see what my art can do Velasquez is
saying to the viewer and to his king and
queen look not to nature or your own
reflection in the mirror for the most
marvelous depiction of your image but to
my canvas
las meninas is an extraordinary
accomplishment for its time but its
effect is timeless it said that King
Phillip the fourth often came to velasca
as a studio just to watch him paint
somehow I think Las Meninas animated his
consciousness as it does mine 360 years
later
indeed to stare at this painting in any
age is to be convinced slowly gradually
and then confidently that you are
witnessing the very best this medium has
to offer
hey everybody thanks for watching and
thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video just amazing like those of
you who pledged on patreon Squarespace
is helping to fund this project keep it
going
and they don't interfere in the content
which is awesome and the product is
actually really great sleek intuitive
professional-looking websites you don't
have to know coding to make it happen
I'm working on something for the
nerdwriter right now which i think is
going to be pretty cool and if you sign
up for a year you can get a free domain
name and if you go to Squarespace comm
and use the offer code nerdwriter
you can get 10% off your first purchase
so that's pretty awesome you can find a
link to all that stuff in the
description below thank you guys for
that and if you want to pledge to the
project directly you can obviously go to
my patreon by clicking right below this
thank you guys so much and I will see
you next Wednesday Squarespace you
should